uh thank you thank you everyone for for
coming and we're very glad to have uh
Professor Khan jit young visiting us
from uh Chula Longhorn University in
Thailand we were lucky that he was also
coming to the US for other
uh professional reasons and that we got
him to stop by in New Haven and um he is
in the uh he's a lecturer in the
international relations department
um Chile Longhorn and he's a sociologist
by training so I won't do a long
introduction he has a PhD from the
University of Wisconsin he works on
migration refugees um things of you know
close interest for for all of us I won't
do a long introduction because we'd like
to hear from him uh so um Professor
jitian please take it away
all right um thank you mufiq for the
introductions and then
um good afternoon everyone to those of
you in the room and also those of you
who join our live we assume uh I'm
honored to to have an opportunities to
to give these lectures as part of the
Fall seminar series of the Yale's
programs on refugees and false
migrations false displacement and also
humanitarian responses
and I'm particularly grateful to Too
Much week for for the invitations to
Teresa who is here with us to Tarana
um Marcus Courtney and also Arlene who
will help with the arrangement
um for my visit to your campus today
um before delving into my my talk for
today please allow me to to give to
preliminary precautions which I think
are worthwhile to mention beforehand
first English is not my native tongue so
I may have difficulties conveying some
thoughts concisely on this challenging
subjects but I will try my very best and
and additionally I speak very fast and
often get tested so when I get nervous
so making me known as a rapper among my
students so besides I I still have chat
lag from traveling you know 13 hours
ahead of time to be here with you so
these combined reasons May perhaps help
justify my reading of of these talks for
today second this lecture is based on
one of my working papers which I I
started three years ago
but I still have not been able to finish
it and every time you know when I get
back to to work on this particular paper
there will always be a new addition to
my LS thoughts and also my thinkings and
then I start moving forward perhaps it
was for these reasons that I decided to
give a talk based on this working paper
hoping that I will be able to finish it
eventually and I'm not saying this to to
actually manage or to diminish your
expectations but I mentioned this in the
hope of gathering your thoughts and
feedback for me to improve this
particular paper
for those of you who may not be familiar
with Bangkok or Thailand and the refugee
situation is there please allow me to
provide some context and factual
information about the cities and
countries which can help the foundations
for my lectures today
first Thailand is a country located in
Southeast Asia with Bangkok being its
capital
has approximately 70 million people
around 15 percent of whom are around
10.5 million live in Bangkok
you can if you include in HSN provinces
which form the Bangkok metropolitan's
areas the entire population will
increase to approximately 15 to 16
million people
second among millions of people living
in the Bank of metropolitan areas are
thousands of urban refugees from at
least 44 countries the official data is
from the unscr office in Bangkok
suggests that there are five thousands
of them however based on the
observations of both CSO and also my own
research team we think that the actual
number of refugees should be between
five thousand and twenty thousand people
the major countries of Origins for urban
refugees in Bangkok including Pakistan
Vietnam Somalia Afghanistan Iran Sri
Lanka and also Palestine
these groups of urban refugees that I
will discuss are just these groups of
people my talk will not include the new
arrivals from Myanmar whose situation is
more complicated and complex but please
feel free to ask questions related to
them during the USA later
third Thailand is one of those countries
in South and Southeast Asia which are
not which are a non-signatory State
student 1951 conventions relating to the
status of refugees and its 1967 protocol
however it has a long history of refugee
management
Thailand also allows unscr to conduct
refi status determination or ISD But the
irony is that the Thai government does
not recognize the unscr card for the
refugee status and just before the
covid-19 pandemic started Thailand
enacted it first Refugee law to deter to
determine the status of those who
generally need protections the
mechanisms has become known as the
national screening mechanisms or NSM the
mechanism has not yet been enforced
since the eligibility the eligibility
criteria that I was part of drafting
Committee just got approved by the
cabinet last week the fact that Thailand
is a non-signitary state and the NSM is
not yet operating refugees continue to
be illegal migrants the terms that the
Thai immigration Bureau used to refer to
these groups of people
officially refugees are subjected to
arrest and detention and just on the day
I arrived in the U.S
12 them from the command Rome Community
were arrested and detained in the
immigration Detention Center thus as
several Scholars of refugees in Thailand
have criticized and Illustrated it is
not an exaggeration to say that Urban
refugees in Bangkok continue to live in
fear and also in a very hostile
environment
my lectures today will highlight a
parallel situations in which Refugee
asylums in Bangkok continues to be
possible
despite what I describe as fear or
hostile environment just now
more importantly Urban refugees continue
to arrive in Bangkok regardless of the
difficulties they may face or endure in
the cities and let me start my lectures
today with some anecdotes
yes here's How The Story begins
so while conducting fewer in Bangkok in
December 2018 I had an opportunity to
meet Junior among refugees teen through
a local lawyer at the church near Don
Moen International Airport
at the time of our encounters the lawyer
did not inform me who junior really was
apart from saying that he was a
community volunteer
as a teenagers walk toward us Junior
agreed at me with a Y with high gestures
and introduced himself in time
Junior greeted me
and say
hi
his time was Flawless and I could not
help thinking that he was a local Irish
staff working for the law for lawyer's
office
only after our conversation a few
minutes later I realized I was wrong
junior is a refugee registered with
unscr who has come to live in Thailand
since he was a boy together with his
family of six
he was the second child of the Hmong
pastor who fled to Thailand due to
religious persecution in Northern
Vietnam
his tie was Flawless because if he did
go to the Thai primary school before
quitting to help earn income for his
family
Junior also speak Thai with his siblings
and friends in the same community and at
home however Junior has continued to be
able to speak his native tongue he also
learned English at the church and his
fathers encouraged him to study Chinese
these language skills landed him a job
as a translator for various Refugee
organizations where he continued to work
nowadays
Cena were first encounter
I have become a frequent visitors to
Junior's family and his community
I participated in some of their
activities I learned several remarkable
insights from their experiences and
livelihoods in Bangkok and let me
mention this a few
Junior's father in the pastors is at the
core of the community
is not only a spiritual guy but also a
community leader who plays a role in
structuring the Exile community
at the end of Sunday mass he often took
the opportunity to Foster Community
spirit and unity
in the absence of Justice in Thailand
due to their lack of legal status
in the absence of access to Justice
talks my apologies the process and some
key community members serve as the
elders who adjudicate Community
conflicts and familiar disputes
the elders also play an essential role
in bringing employment opportunities to
community members
they leverage their social network
primarily to the Hmong people who have
already been living in Thailand for
decades and from the previous employers
to get people to work
not everyone is employed
although they can get jobs I must note I
must note that these jobs are available
in the informal sectors with no legal
contracts
this includes a translation job that
Junior has as well
the home of the pastors and the church
serve as a community centers where
community activities occur
before the covid-19 pandemic while
adults and teens would go to mass on
Sunday the second floor of the home of
the hostage would turn into a nursery
where volunteers would come and teach
English to young kids
the first floor of the house also serves
as a community Workshop where ladies
would go and engage in making
handicrafts and products
like this
some of these are all are sold through
the traveling projects established by
local Refugee organizations to empower
female refugees
despite opportunities
the Hmong Community is also face
challenges because of they say illegally
in Thailand raids and arrests still
affect community members however in many
instances Thai neighbors helped Shield
them from by providing information about
police monitoring in the area so they
will not be able to so they will not be
subjected to arrest and detentions
during the covid-19 pandemic the
informal structures of the community
also play a vital role in spreading
information about covid-19 preventions
and help and helping manage those
getting infected
and this is the pictures from the mass
at the church that they gathered every
Sunday
some part of the stories such as the
existence of a community Elders may be
unique to the Moon Community however
based on interviews that my team and I
conducted with refugees from 10
nationalities in 10 communities the
overall experiences of refugees are
strikingly similar
ranging from the stories of their
Journeys into Thailand people over
studying their visa
and get to stay in Thailand more longer
to the store is a pathway to get
employment and their experience of urban
Institution
the story I just told you may also
resonate with Urban Refugee experiences
in other countries as well
if these stories are so common why do I
still mention them
I mentioned them because these stories
bring me to the key puzzles for my talk
today how is Refugee asylums in Thailand
possible despite the hostile
legal environments how could we explain
these
phenomenon
there are various factors of course
elsewhere I did extend the role of the
social network the importance of the
Thai government policies and the
existence of refugee organizations and
unscr office
but what about the space where they live
like the city
how does the city shape and make Refugee
asylums possible how should we
understand the connection between the
cities and refugees especially their
abilities to navigate livelihoods in the
cities without legal status
and writes personally I think Refugee
Scholars have taken the connections
between the cities and refugees for
granted and too likely they focus
excessively on the relative advantages
that the cities bring to refugees
compared to those in can such as free
mobilities
employment opportunities
I do not deny these explanations but I
believe that we can better theorize the
refugees cities Nexus and this is what
exactly I'm trying to accomplish by the
end of this talk today
therefore I am trying to bring Urban
studies to contribute to Refugee studies
in my talk
to explain how refugees construct their
asylums in the non-signatory states
my argument is as follow
the city is three forms of powers
including environmental discursive and
mature Powers have both the resilience
of refugees by providing them with three
essential capacities for City
navigations and through which it allows
the refugees to be able to construct
asylums even in the context of a
non-signatory state in Thailand
I will now introduce two interrelated
Concepts which is Central to my
arguments and my explanations Urban
power and Refugee resilience
Urban power
for those of you who study Urban
politics and urban studies the
terrorists in Norway knew
for decades we have seen the emergence
all these other discussions about Urban
power for example in the famous book who
governs by Robert Downs who taught here
at Yale and wrote and brought about the
cities of New Haven also let us to
understand Urban power structure
from there we also seeing the growing
literatures on Urban power relations
power in the cities or even cities of
power which is the title of a book by by
thurbonne that just came out four years
ago power in the cities continue to be a
recurring theme in urban Affairs
nowadays although some have moved on to
talk about Urban governance for example
on the other hand Urban power is also
discussed among sociologists and
geographers who have looked into urban
powers from a slightly different
perspective this seems to focus more on
the power of place in space and the
power of the cities and how did these
shape social relations and interactions
we often hear them Proclaim Place
matters we have seen the classic
sociological world of Samson's on
neighborhood effects which attempts to
explain how the neighborhoods can be an
essential determinants of socioeconomic
stratifications
for me Urban power relations as well as
social interactions are quite crucial
for the construction of life and of the
Cities I look into the work of a
geographer like Robert satch who argued
that the power of place and space comes
only from the end quote the original
rules about what is in and our place but
again who made those rules
it is those who govern that place and
perhaps those who those who comes from
social interactions that give meaning to
such a place
for this reason these multiple social
political and economic relations
eventually lend power to the city it was
from this Urban power that new arrivals
for example migrants or refugees who
derive their resilience and integrate
into the cities
because of there are multiple forms of
relations and governance in the cities
there can be various forms of urban
power today my talks will focus on only
three forms environmental discursive and
and material powers
all the urban powers can be Elusive and
style abstracts I believe it would be
worthwhile to Define it as a form
of power embedded in the cities emerging
from complex relations that shape the
Dynamics of the cities and the city
constructions
second the term Refugee resilience
from a rather traditional Concepts that
I introduced just now I would like to
move on to discuss the more fashionable
term resilience which has been used
widely in various field
generally the terms refer to positive
adaptations and capabilities to recover
from challenges and setbacks quickly
some Scholars even treat resilience as a
paradigm
in Refugee studies resilience is also
very popular especially among those
studying Refugee well-being and those
focusing on livelihood adjustment and
strategies my usage of the term is also
pretty straightforward
I adopt these terms because I see it as
more encompassing for me it is suitable
because when we talk about resilience we
can look into two interconnected
components of capacities the first is to
have capacities and the second is
connected to the abilities to use such
capacities to make difference in the
situations and life situations in
particular
with the concept of resilience it is
also important to note that we can give
agency back to Refugee themselves as
many states often take that away from
them and put them into a position as a
burden or dependence
in conceptualizing resilience most
literatures would focus more on
resilience that come from within meaning
to look into their mental adjustment
inner self and available resources and
social network
but for me when we think about
resilience our Refugee is resilience in
particular especially in the context of
urban refugees resilience also come from
the city itself
different forms of urban power provide
various capacities and in my talk you
will see
which I'm not going to show you later on
in the table
that um from which sort these resilience
are coming from
different form of urban power provide
various capacities
and to repeat my arguments again the CD3
forms which including material
discursive and environmental Powers they
have bolsters
materials discursive and environmental
capacities
now that I have made foundations for my
Essential framework for the subject
matters please allow me to delve into
details for each one of them and then
also to provide you with some empirical
evidence
the empirical evidence which provide
insights into what I'm presenting today
has come from ethnographic fewer that
have been conducted in Thailand for the
past three years observing communities
activities
and engage with them having
conversations with those ends of local
csos and also more than 140 interviews
that my team and I conducted with
refugees back in 2020s these interviews
were conducted as party attempts to
understand Refugee integration in
Thailand and it was conducted via
telephone we adopt this method since at
that time it was the beginning of the
pandemic and we were not able to put to
get into the community they were
conducted over the period of four months
between September and December 2020s and
a team of five people including myself
we we engaged in Disney to be all
together
now
going into detail for each one of them
these are the form of urban Powers I'm
talking about and the form of resilience
that correspond with different Urban
powers
I start first from I will start first
with the first form of urban power which
is an urban environmental Powers which
is corresponding with the environmental
capacities
when hearing the term environmental
powers
people often go back to the work and the
thinking of of toasting women who argue
in the theory of the laser class that
environmental power emerge from how
people demonstrate their command of the
environment through their wealth and
social positions environmental power
therefore would become an indicator of
Social Power
based on weapons insights disadvantages
people may also have environmental power
if we think of this in the relative
terms but their power would be lessons
to the wealthier and those with higher
Social positions however the critical
questions we also have to ask is where
is environmental Powers comes from well
you need
you need access to the environment first
to be able to command it
if that's the case then this
environmental power is not simply
related but come from human interactions
with the environment to a man or change
the Landscapes build new structures
through the social interactions that
human has with the environment it is
unsurprising that power is also led to
the restructured environment also giving
the environment the so-called power as
well in turn which can be that which can
then be land to anyone including those
with less power like refugees
let me put this in more concrete terms
of urban refugees when I'm talking about
the environment in these contexts I'm
talking mainly about the built
environment this is all the physical
parts of where we live rest work and
perform or engage in various activities
in a city such as Bangkok
the build environment is is complex
buildings become a fortress where people
can shoot themselves from one another
these form of social interactions
between humans and the beer environment
made the environmental power of the city
very powerful Authority cannot penetrate
all areas unless there are reports from
those living in those built environment
people can become invisible behind the
concrete walls in their privates
apartment
these former Urban Powers therefore
learn refugees the environmental
capacities to make a decision to command
how they will use the build environment
to Shield themselves or enhance other
social and economic benefits
usually they will prioritize safety why
as I mentioned before refugees are
considered as illegal migrants in
Thailand they can be arrested and
detained for example one palestinian's
family I visited will close their house
door most of the time
whether they are inside or not
sabiha always said to me we always feel
safer here in this house when we close
the door but actually the side of the
house itself is also a very safe place
because it's located in the gated
communities of most Thai people but
being in the commodity environment made
refugees feel a double layers of cell
protections the housing choice is also
related to their access to a moss and
also job sites
however it's essential to note that when
a number of refugees moving into a
community and other areas together the
city environmental Powers May hinder the
refugee's environmental capacities as
well there were several incidents of
refugees getting arrested because of the
neighborhood reported a high
concentrations of foreigners or refugees
living in the areas to local police
the second form of urban power that I
will be discussing is discursive power
this form of powers
this form of urban Powers emerged from
the city's densities varieties and
diversities of people places and states
the city has posed this power perhaps
since the city started to expand
we can trace back to the work of worth
on urbanisms in 1938 where he talks
about the heterogeneity of people in the
cities and the little works of others
Urban sociologists who have discussed
anonymities in the cities
what does it mean due to the capacity of
the people the city provides capacities
for refugees to move in and out of
labels depending on place and space in
the context of this discursive Powers
particularly in the context of Thailand
I'm talking about the new categories of
people labeled as
refugee migrants
because of Thailand is a non-signitary
state as I mentioned before and always
refugees are not recognized as refugees
even those with unscr cards they are
known as a person of concerns to unscr
and they prefer to identify themselves
as migrants especially to the locals who
are potential employers
the urban discursive Powers therefore
allow refugees to de-link and Grilling
their own stories making them in command
of their labels this is precisely what
stiputat and Sorensen says that refugees
in quote had a very context dependence
and pragmatics relationship to their
labels end quote
in extreme cases
that's what I mentioned already in
extreme cases Urban discursive Powers
also allow some refugees to pass as time
Parsons refers to the process by which
in an individual can cross over from one
identity to another based on specific
attributes in the case of urban refugees
in Thailand that is the Thai language
fluencies combined with a similar
physical appearance
passing is a forceful form of discursive
capacities for urban Refugee used to
avoid getting arrests if police
encounter them on the street or at the
construction site
alarm among refugees for example
mentioned to be in quote we look like
Thai people and speak the language well
so we cannot get the way so we can get
away with many things in Thailand and
put
last but not least the material Powers
which does not need much explanations
this is perhaps the most widely
discussed connections between refugees
and the cities
the urban material Powers emerged from
the economic relations in the cities we
have seen multiple economics barriers of
the Cities either being The Sire
Productions or the locals of class
strato
economic relation helps structures Urban
material Powers this power in turns
structures social relations between
economic agents namely employers and
also employees
what the city use to Urban refugees in
the case of Thailand is capacities in
the economic realm or material
capacities which allows them to navigate
employment and jobs opportunities and
acquire material needs
Bank of Thailand approximates that size
of the Thai informal economy is between
45 to 50 percent and has absolved more
than 60 percent of the workforce in the
countries Bangkok as a country capitals
and economic and financial center of the
countries also serve as a major hub for
the informal sectors
our interviews reviewed that Bangkok has
provided various economic opportunities
for refugees the extent to which they
could acquire those chances also varies
depending on their skill experiences
Network and connections but let me show
you some data is a bit filed from 140
interviews that we did
74 of the 140 respondents were engaged
in income Gathering activities in the
informal sectors before the pandemic
20 of all the respondents who reported
working in Thailand had working at least
two jobs
and responding wages varies some wages
could be as low as one dollars per day
for picking dry Chili's chips to others
receiving up to 800 or around 20 US
dollars per day working in organizations
depending on their skill required those
low wages perhaps explain why they are
working in multiple jobs
these data as I presented to you here
show not only what a city like Bangkok
can provide for urban refugees but also
the extent Urban refugees have already
contributed with their material
capacities to the Thai economy and the
cities
how the city Urban power enabled them to
have this particular capacities
however the contributions of urban
refugees in Bangkok are lesser known
up to this point
I have already provided a detailed
explanations of the interactions between
urban powers and Refugee resilience
focusing on three forms of capacities as
I mentions
and these Urban powers and the
corresponding forms of verification
capacities which I frame them as a
refugees resilience helped make Asylum
possible for urban refugees even in the
context of a non-signatory States like
thailands
Auto focusing on both factors I just
want to repeat it again that I recognize
the significance of some other factors
that I mentioned at the beginning of my
talk
before I end this talk
I would like to address one final issues
regarding the sustainabilities of the
silence
Auto City like Bangkok can provide Haven
for refugees the fact that refugees can
settle their asylums with Urban powers
and resilience has also become a
barriers for their onward moving for
their onward movement and limbo as a
refugees
let me now revisit the stories of the
Hmong communities that I started
in June 2019 I received at Junior's
family as usual and this time I had a
chance to discuss with his father Pastor
for almost two hours
he told me that his families face
resettlement challenges
a sponsor in Canada told the pastors
that he wants the sponsors they want to
sponsor someone else who is really in
need since the passive family seems to
be better off in Bangkok
the pastor told me with low voice in
quotes
I was quite surprised that he said that
to me we are indeed better off
economically in Bangkok but that is what
we must do to survive
it does it also doesn't means we will
need protections
the Thai government didn't recognize our
status
[Music]
because of their because of the
resettlement uncertainties
the process is currently exploring other
options for his families
one of them was to help junior or
another
of his sons get recital first either in
Canada or somewhere else
he's also preparing for the worst in the
families and the communities we must
continue living in Thailand for years to
come
and he's saying quote God will paved our
wake and vote
being able to seek Asylum is one thing
but moving to the third country is
another and the ladders continue to be
the hope of nearly all Urban refugees in
Thailand despite knowing that this hands
has become increasingly Limited
as Thailand was soon launched its own
National screening mechanisms providing
Urban refugees with temporary legal
status while seeking asylums in Thailand
it's also the time to see whether Urban
refugees will change their perceptions
regarding Asylum seeking in Bangkok in
fact many do not merely seek asylums in
the cities but have already integrated
into the Thai Society in some way
whether it is asylums or Integrations I
believe that Urban power and Refugee
resilience are part of the ingredients
making the livelihoods of these Urban
refugees continue
to be a path of survival
I want to end my talk with some key
implications first
see this may be another factor is
contributing to Refugee asylums but it
is indeed the essential one second Urban
power play a significant part in
empowering Refugee agencies and also
enabling their resilience
empowering Refugee is therefore require
the empowerment of the cities and also
the urban power
and finally although constructing
asylums in an unsignatory States may be
challenging the case of urban refugees
in Thailand that I show in my talk today
indicates that it's possible in fact the
possibility of asylum in some
non-signatory States can be far greater
than that in the Symmetry States
that's the end of my talk thank you so
much
for such a wonderful talk
um I am going to serve as a bit of a
moderator so if you have questions maybe
you can raise your hand and
um uh I think we have plenty of time so
you know we can take each one one by one
and you provide an answer then if we
sort of run out of things to discuss I
have some questions in mind as well so
um but I'll I would love for you all ask
your questions first if anyone wants to
start
I'm well I'm happy to like use my um I
guess my power as discussion to ask a
question that I have yes um and then
maybe uh that'll let everyone gather
their thoughts so um one I guess just to
sort of plow the field and make sure
we're we're using the same terms
um I'd love to hear you talk a little
bit about
um why you as a researcher as a kind of
doing the political work you do why you
choose to call these individuals
refugees not migrants and not asylees
um and while you don't adopt the term
that the government uses of refugee Dash
migrant Refugee migrant all right
um and related to that I'm I'm
personally curious about the idea that
um
uh these the urban refugees are
um seeking a space of Asylum
um how does that differentiate from an
acai lead do you use those terms
interchangeably or yeah
um just a little bit more information on
how you conceptualize these different
categories right it's also fine if
they're like not meaningful for you
because of your work but um yeah just so
yeah I think it's really important to
actually go back and think about those
terms as well because of you know the
way I use the term it's it's quite
different from from from some of the you
know like Concepts I've been discussing
elsewhere so when I use the term
refugees it depends and it's actually
based on the cell identification of the
refugees themselves so that's that's how
I because of for example this talk when
I even though I talk about Urban power
right
um how I constructed our focus on the
three form of urban Powers actually come
from the data that I got from refugees
themselves so um if they identify
themselves as refugees of course I take
it as a refugees I would you some
example for example in the case of the
Hmong Community there are a lot of
people who are known as a closed case
these closed case are the people who are
who used to go through the the process
of seeking asylums you know and go
through the ISD process with unscr and
then that case got close right but but
the fact that that clear case got closed
doesn't mean that they are not refugees
it means that because of perhaps they
don't have enough documents or evidence
to actually prove at that time being and
they can go through the process again
right so because of this I feel like it
wouldn't do justice to them if they
identify it elsewhere in in some other
ways you know like for example or in a
way that Thai government would identify
refugees so in the case of Thailand
refugees actually known in in multiple
ways like for example
um the early groups of refugees that
came into Thailand they were known as
the displays Vietnamese displays Laos
and so on and so forth the more reasons
group from Myanmar right also known as
people fleeing
um uh
of people fleeing fighting that was the
first time the first the first group
that came in 1980s and 90s and then the
recent groups it's known that people
fleeing
um uncertainties for example right so
it's a whole bunch of category but then
at the end of the day you know I feel
like oh this term is just related to the
policies that governing them but it
doesn't do justice to the their actual
identities of refugee themselves that's
the first thing second thing when I use
the term refugees migrants though right
that was the time that I also recognized
that if you know like refugees want to
defy themselves differently when they
are talking about different contexts for
example in the context of employment
right in that case I also use the term
migrant as well so it really depends the
way I describe it it really depends on
how they actually uh use the terms you
know basically and for the term asylums
I I the second questions I haven't
thought about that much yet but I I
often use it in the sharing review but
some other times another terms I use
often as well is Refuge but then in
these presentations because I feel like
the term Refuge it means that you know
it it it gives a sense of how
how there will be some structures that
govern them in some ways still right and
to a large degree it's related to the
unscr structures but in the term as
silence that I I chose here it's more
like how it comes from the way that
refugees himself can draw on on their
capacities to build it so that's why I
prefer this term more in presenting this
today yeah hopefully answer both
questions yes you did thank you very
much yes thank you for this doctor it's
really interesting
um I guess I I have two sort of very
different questions the first is why
Thailand has not signed onto the 1951
convention
um and what discussion is taking place
around that and in the government and
then the second one is
um just wondering about the way that you
use resilience
and if you're engaging with critical
like
um
criticism of that term right because a
lot of folks particularly Advocates of
marginalized people have talked about
the way that resilience
um focuses on people and on their
behavior instead of on structures that
are constraining them or producing them
right and so I wonder how you kind of
reconciled
Concepts okay let me go start from the
first question why Thailand is not
signing the conventions
um
I haven't traced about the history of
rooftop Management in Thailand and
actually it's about politics of um
how Thailand sees it positions way back
in 1950. so in 1950 actually the early
groups of refugees that came to Thailand
are the kmt soldiers they came from
China during that time and there was
there were a lot a lot of them were
settles there but at the same time
during that period of time
um there was also a dispute in um the
icj regarding one of the territories of
Thailand that related to Cambodia I
think this is part of the reasons why in
the calculations of the Thai government
at that time that you know I did first
they don't want to hold responsibilities
of taking care of refugees that's the
first thing but second thing is that
because they're afraid of the dividing
you know of the obligations that were
related to the case at the icga at that
time also that was a historical reasons
but then in the modern periods there
have been four times that there was
research conducted on shoe Thailand you
know sign the conventions and all the
research that came out say that Thailand
outside of convention and they're going
to do the fifth one very soon actually
whether or not they're going to start
the conventions but the arguments right
now is that because of the content in
the conventions are no longer related to
the real world situations it's not up to
date basically right and Thailand always
have one argument which I think that
also resonates with some other countries
that we do more already than the
signatory states why should we do the
conventions for example one of the
examples that Thailand will use likely
in this December Refugee forum is that
we already you know creating the
national screen mechanisms and with this
mechanism this could be a a replacement
of of the conventions right so that's
that's the kind of thing that that
Thailand feel that you know like if the
refugee conventions get updated and then
we also have some other thing else you
know that we're already doing so then
that unless that updated version is
there then we would sign the conventions
that otherwise they would not not agree
to sign the conventions I believe and
they don't see the the the importance of
it also so
um in terms of that nevertheless saying
that doesn't mean that Thailand does not
really oblige to the international you
know the responsibilities at all because
there are some other
um instruments that make Thailand you
know taking care of refugees also and
what's more important and also is that
if you look into the text of the
national screening mechanisms which I
mentioned the definitions of
persecutions and also the definition of
refugees it's expanding it goes beyond
the definitions in the conventions so in
that case you know like it's quite
Progressive in a sense but then we have
to see whether in the interpretation of
it will it retains that progressiveness
or not
um so that's to answer the questions on
on the signing of the conventions
the term resilience yeah I mean I think
that's really interesting the way you
ask the questions because of I I have to
admit that I did not engage much with
the critical side of that yet and then I
I try to go along with the mainstream in
itself but when I think about the
resilience here as I mentioned it's also
related to the capacities of damage
itself
um and it's the lending from the
structures that resilience emerge right
so I'm not talking about resilience of
the structure in itself but I'm talking
about how the power within the structure
like urban urban power is the one that
lend this resilience to the capacity so
it at the end of the day still focus on
on the people themselves and how they'll
be able to to have that capacities but
then when I'm talking about the
capacities here the reason why I decided
to use the term resilience at first when
I started off this paper I didn't use
the term resilience I using the term
capacities but then one of my colleagues
criticized that usage in a way that when
you think about capacities alone you are
assuming that they just have it but
you're not talking about how they
actually be able to spring back but in
the case of refugees you know you start
just having capacities but they use
these capacities to make something else
happening for them and that means
aligning with possibilities and so on so
in this case that's why I go to the term
resilience and I go with the term
resilience for that reasons to also
extend
um the part of capacities from not just
having capacities but to focus on how
they use the capacities to construct the
asylums basically yeah
foreign there is a question from
somebody
on zoom and agreed that if Urban power
especially the built environment and
environmental power is considered to be
a central component of refugee
resilience in a city with such a hostile
environment to what extent to
development projects like stream
cleanups and other physical changes to
the city affect this power are there any
pathway for refugees or their Advocates
to be a part of City Planning at this
point okay I think in some I think this
is really depends on the context now
this is where the context really matters
a lot
in the case of Bangkok right now I think
that refugees are being part of the
construction of the Cities because of
one of the key jobs that several Refugee
books are engaging it's actually the
construction of the Cities the
constructing work and so on and if you
look into the the survey I mean in other
public schools of my on on the human
capacity on their human capitals it
shows that most of them identify
construction as being their own skill
that they already have so in that sense
you know in terms of being engaged in
the construction of the cities in a way
of the create the creation of the build
environment they were part of it but now
in terms of the city planning this is
another question that refugees at least
in the context of Thailand they're not
able to do so yet and the reason why
because of of course you know they have
the lack of legal status and because of
the lack of legal state that it means
that they are not or they are they are
also
um afraid of even going out in order to
be exposed or to be visible most of the
time and because of the the fear of
being visible in that sense it leads
them you know been to taking part in
terms of you know planning or engaging
in policies second thing not all groups
of refugees engage or speak Thai
language right and only certain groups
of them that really you speak Thai and
because of this you know like it also
part the reasons why refugees were not
you know really
um engage in that kind of planning and
so on so most of them you know still
dream of Transit through Thailand the
transit words the terms that that in in
the world of Covington's it's got
constructed to different
um factors and so on but but it also in
the imagination of refugeeism said that
they want to translate through Thailand
and go somewhere else and because of the
the the thinking about transiting to to
Thailand and to go somewhere else it
made them less engaged politically or
internal planning on the cities and so
on so forth nevertheless because of the
resettlement opportunity become limited
nowadays um several Refugee
organizations within the countries
particularly local CSO engage more in in
empowering refugees so that they can be
part of this city planning but then I
mean in some other cases perhaps I think
it may be viable but in the case of you
know context of Bangkok at the moment I
don't think that it's okay that yeah
and and then I follow up from that our
children for example allowed to go to
school so what happens to the Next
Generation basically right do they
consider or view themselves this is the
most important question so one thing is
that refugees in Thailand can go to
school all students can go to Thai
school and it's it's it's guarantee in
the Constitutions that all kids in the
country regardless of what race
ethnicities they are they can go to
school but then when you go to school
the school also teach everything in a
Thai language right so that's part of
the reason why some of them do not do
not go to Thai school and then because
of some of them want to just make a
Transit and not make a living in Bangkok
so they decided not to send their kids
to the school that's the decision to
Refugee themselves second things was
that it's also about the structures when
refugees going to the Thai school what
happened is that sometimes the
principles may make decisions not to
admit them into school or even if
they're already in the school they're
not allowed or encourage them to
continue their studies in a higher level
by not giving them for example the
certificate right so it's a challenge
it's not simply just in terms of you
know the access is already there but how
the maneuvering of the behind it it's
become something that borrow the access
and at the same time for them to
actually climb up the ladders and become
successful within the context of
Thailand it also limited because of
because of that structure in itself
nevertheless one one good news that is
coming in from the case of Thailand is
that um if you look into the the
convention on the right of children
um Thailand is the last country in the
world to reserve
um articles 22nd which is focused
specifically on the rise of the refugee
student so this year it's it's the year
that Thailand is trying to you know
withdraw from that particular articles
and I have an opportunities to be able
to take part in that process as well so
they are they are laying The Growler to
plan for the withdrawal from the the CRC
related to uh article 22. so that should
provide a pathway for children and to
integrate more into Thailand and to get
more support for them
um yes
um yeah so I have two questions one is
about I was really struck by your use of
like environment uh particularly like
speaking on the urban environment
because like from the perspective
environmental history it's quite
separate from Urban history where the
urban is not considered as part of the
environment
um so I'm just wondering like how does
nature figure in the kind of research
that you do especially thinking about
questions of refugee narratives of
um like landscape memory and place like
Place making
um you know like because they are the
space they probably come from a kind of
different landscape than the bank of
urban environment like how does that
change their experience how do they
negotiate with that
um the second question I have that I
have is um how does your This research
like relate to
um like current studies of globalization
and refugees like I'm thinking
specifically about like the work of
modern Matthews and
um and about like choking mentions
um the ghetto of the end of the center
of the world
um where you know that in that
particular example Hong Kong is both
aspirational for or kind of middle class
in developing countries but also
but also they are marginalized right
within Hong Kong Society so is there a
kind of similar Dynamic that's played
out in your research you uh That You
observe all right thank you so much
Marcus so let me start from the first
questions to think about the change of
the of the experience actually you know
one thing that I find is so interesting
was that because of as I mentioned in
the stories you know at the beginning of
the Hmong Community right once they move
to Thailand and the lack of legal status
lack of access to Justice For example
what would be the alternative then that
is the time when they adopt you know
like the structure the social structures
that they had already in their home
countries over into Thailand so it's
kind of the the replications of that
structure is that already at play there
but at the same time you know they also
out they also try to match it with the
context that is also already different
okay that that's the first the second
part of the first questions that I
answered the thing that I think about
environment I think that you know when
you think about environment it it's
there are multiple Dimensions to
environment right when we when we when
we hear about the word environment of
course we think about the forest the
forests the nature and so on but but if
you think about the second Dimensions or
the second phase of the environment it's
something around us here it could be a
rhetorical in a sense right or if you
think about the third environment it
should be something that God describes
somewhere and so on so there are
multiple ways or multiple Dimensions to
the terms environment itself and the way
I use it it's to to focus it more like
it based on not just in nature but the
the amending of the nature in a way that
allows everything else to be built on
that nature so nature may be there as a
ground so on and so forth but on on top
of that it got those built environment
that that had become part of my
explanations so I hope that I answers
most of the uh the first question both
parts of the first question the second
question is intimidate marginalization
yes the answer is yes that they got
marginalized within the cities and most
of the time many of them will pushed
into poverties so if you see I did not
show you the data I said that I that I
gathered from the interview
um the 140 interviews that I did it was
the case that um most of the refugees
themselves after covid-19 hits really
hard they were push out of the jobs so
they no longer have it at all like even
some of the home base and and workshop
of someone's and they were they become
more dependent than ever on um on on on
on AIDS nevertheless you know it's not
all the communities are the same some
communities that have a strong structure
that they imported from the the the the
home countries that for example the
hormone Community their resigning was
was still going strong and very well
they can spring back pretty quickly
right so in that case you know like I
think the degree to marginalizations it
depends on the degrees in which they
integrate into the societies and how
they expand the network based on that
Integrations so it's it's come down to
that questions and then I think that we
cannot say that all our group of urban
refugees are the Institute I mean there
are groups that are really really
marginalized comparing to the other so
it's a matter of degrees I think to a
large extent
foreign we have now a question from
adelin
hi thank you so much for your talk I
wish I wish I was there um so just to
follow up on this I had I had a couple
questions so the first was about this
question about integration right so
between Thai and more people
um I'm wondering how how do they
negotiate the identity you mentioned
that they were able to speak very good
Thai and different languages I'm
wondering you know to what extent do
they navigate this identity issue in a
sense of like do they believe in um you
know some like Buddhists like Tire
Customs or practices do they bring in
their own kind of practices as well to
what extent do they conceive of nature
in a way that you know Thai people would
versus Hmong people
um because for example when I was
talking to Hmong people
um in in Northern Thailand had very
different conceptions of like causality
for like natural disasters and and how
to then address that
um and for example without Heats out
hung the very the different animistic
ways of dealing with with
um uh understanding the world I'm just
curious to what extent they integrate
you know in in their kind of
metaphysical as well as kind of like
identity practices and language
um sorry the second question was about
power um and in Thai studies that's just
kind of like tension between part of me
and I'm not right this idea about kind
of like moral power versus like an
authority over something does that
figure into this form of power or is it
more a different form of power like or a
capability that you're seeing as an
empowering uh term I'm just wondering
how this term of power relates between
the languages or I I don't speak Hmong
but uh maybe something that they might
be thinking about as well and sorry the
last question is about networks um so
you mentioned in the material power
section and the informal economy that
opportunities depends on network skills
and connections and I think there's a
very interesting parallel with um
injuries paper she she did a journal
article on Thai Karen and she talked
about amid their legal precarity they
have the sense of uh resilience through
their networks right so I'm wondering
for these Hmong people what what are
their networks like what is a good
Network what is not a good Network how
are they you know bringing in their
social structures or not
um and what what that looks like thank
you all right thank you so much out
because the question is focus more on
the Hmong community and then that's my
talk you know the future both what this
particular Community both at the
beginning and at the end so I I will
first have Dimensions about the network
itself the network is the most important
part of their resilience I mean
particularly for the home Community
because of these networks because of it
it comes not simply just because they
are already in Bangkok but it started
actually over a long period of time
that's not even before they moved into
Thailand they always known some of the
people you know like within the one
community and then they all I already
have a separated groups of the Hmong
communities you know like across
Thailand that I was in Vietnam and they
know an amount itself right so this
network was fostered not just simply
because of the moving to Thailand and
they found that that network but then
they didn't know about this network for
quite some time and perhaps this is part
of the reasons why they integrated into
um
into
um into Thailand for that reason also
alhamdul Thailand that before that
reasons the second thing I really have
to mention about the network that they
have is that if you look on your opinion
into the employment opportunities that
they be able to gather particularly for
the Hmong Community it's actually also
in the historic areas where the Hmong
people used to stay including the Lao
moms that came into Thailand that for
example in the areas near Sarah Province
and so on and so forth so that's for
example once they have no job
opportunities in Bangkok some of the
people would go into those areas in
order to get the opportunities and so on
and so forth
um in terms of the identity itself I
don't think that I can comment more
specifically on the language because I
wanted to think that that I I have to
say is that um
or the language part I I communicate
with among people through either Thai
language because of they already as I
mentioned integrated in in Thailand to a
large degree so the way that they
express themselves or talk to me right
it's always in in that high language
itself but behind the scenes whether or
not how they reconcile it with um with a
with the devil language and that one
coaches I cannot mentions more
specifically on that
um and also in turn the last part of the
questions of power the question of power
is in terms of moral powers and so on
and so forth that I I already mentioned
also I I haven't thought about that much
yet so perhaps that's the reason why I
haven't included in this presentation
for today so I cannot comment more
specifically on that on that part also
for the time being but then that would
let me think more about it because of
there was one idea that came out from
the Notions of moral power that you know
even though like when it comes to the
policy of managing refugees in Thailand
there would be some form of the moral
powers that kind of that that Kai was of
being used you know like in order to to
actually allow these people to stay in
the countries I I got and that got
mentioned several times already to me
but nevertheless I have never get a
chance to really delve into details of
those so I cannot comment more
specifically on that oh sorry
I would be interested in asking you to
pick up on the last point that you
mentioned
um I guess it was the second to last
about intersectionality and the
different identities of these groups
both in relation to uh before when we
met earlier we talked briefly about you
know these groups fans Somali
um refugees Refuge from Pakistan and
then refugees from neighboring countries
so the kind of experience of moving
through the city for those different
groups must be very different but also
maybe you could speak a bit on on gender
um
uh other anything else that feels
significant to you in in terms of what
impacts the way that people wield this
power that you've identified differently
I think that it's really important to
mention intersectionalities I didn't
bring it in into my discussions here at
first because it's not related directly
to the powers but then of course I mean
this Urban power is not chair
um equally among different groups of
people so different groups of people
draw different
um I mean the capacity they can draw
from these Urban Powers is kind of
diverse and different depending on the
groups for example we in with regards to
the Somali right as as mentioned Somali
is always gets spotted within the Thai
societies partially because of you know
like they they look different in
comparing to like Hmong people or some
other groups that are from neighboring
countries right so the chance for them
to actually integrate it into a Thai
societies is limited comparing to other
groups and then whenever they gather
together in certain groups in certain
areas they always get Spotify and then
that's how you know they arrest of these
groups are become more become something
that that got my comments and and then
in many cases I mean many incidents you
know after arrests and detentions occur
with the groups of African um refugees
it occurred through the fact that
because of the Thai immigration bureaus
um try to label you know like some
operations that Focus specifically on
smuggling and so on and so forth of
these groups of people into Thailand and
because of this what happened is that
they become victims of that you know
like arrests and detentions and so on
also um so in in terms of the the
intersections of being you know like
um
uh and then and then that that's just on
ethic ethnicities quite early but now
you know another thing that's more
important though is that if we think
about gender and race also together
right what is what what become clear to
me also is that it also matters in the
way that how they got treated and so on
and so forth that for example in in the
case of Thailand even though the arrests
mostly occur when it comes to the male
refugees when it comes to female
refugees right the the chance or the
livelihoods of getting getting arrested
is less and when it comes to other
groups um lgbtqi plus their livelihoods
in Thailand is also very difficult
particularly if they live together with
people from their own Community why
because of um most of these people you
know they've imported the same social
structure from their own countries right
one of the Somali refugees who are
lgbtqia I bet for example got expelled
from the community and also experience
violence
um within Thailand as well but then he
cannot access to justice justice so the
only way out for him to escape from the
community and go and stay somewhere else
for example right so in that case you
know that these multiple identities of
the people also have an impact on how
they're going to be able to survive
within the cities and even even though
you know like they already survived it
doesn't mean that that's going to be the
case in the upcoming years and so on and
so forth so I think to think more about
intersectionalities in the context of
Library groups I think it's important
and then I think that I haven't done
that well enough here in these
presentations today because I think that
different groups really draw on the the
powers differently so at the end of the
day the degree to Refugee resilience
which is if these different capacities
also varies in degree as well yeah
foreign
for visiting us and it's a pleasure to
have you here in person thank you so
much and thank you so much for having me
here